apparently ariana grande does have tears
left to cry at least when it comes to
Pete Davidson Nicki Minaj doubles down
on the normanni defense+ what you didn't
see on a GT last night America's Got
Talent was wild wacky and a little
spooky last night we got that tea for
you guys in just a bit but fresh off
their PDA fest at the VMAs ariana grande
and Pete Davidson are proven they're the
real deal I had my doubts because was it
moving too fast
yeah people posed only three weeks after
going public as a couple okay but Ari
opened up to GMA and there was some
genuine emotion that got me checking
myself I work so much I've never like
spent this much time or energy like
planning something personal that like
feeds my soul so much of my heart my
cries I'm just so excited
but like it's sick it's really fun but
now it's not soon so it's gonna be like
next year he also crashed that interview
reminding former New York giant Michael
string and how they bonded after Pete's
dad died in 9/11 and Ariana of course
has dealt with trauma of her own after
last year's Manchester bombing a source
tells ET the couple bonded in part
because they are able to share openly
what they have faced that's that real
real so I want to go on the record right
now and ship this I fought it for too
long you guys they're out of seven right
now on the John and Chrissy scale of
relationship goes but they are on their
way up and you know Pete and Ariana are
reppin themselves almost as hard as
nicki minaj reps normanni
and she doubled down on her clap back to
Tiffany Haddish is fifth harmony shade
at the VMAs you remember the one
covenant and so don't be coming for big
harmony because normanni is that [ __ ]
I'm just saying no I love you she's just
saying and Nikki defended normani
again this time on Queen radio where she
really had some things to say I'd like
to you know shout out now last night at
the VMAs I said normanni is that [ __ ]
because she is and I won't allow anyone
to disrespect a black woman in my face
I'm done I've had it I've had it with
the greatest rapper alive is she wrong
no and that ringing endorsement gotten
Romani's attention she tweeted I love
you You perfect Queen you thank you for
lifting me up God is real now you'll
y'all know I love me some Nikki my
question is what about the rest of the
ladies of five H Lauren seemingly
responded at Tiffany's dis she tweeted
waiting for the day when supporting one
successful adult woman does not mean
insult to another successful dope women
all right first of all Tiffany is a
comedian and honestly the VMAs needed
some of that funny shape but Lauren is
right I think there's room for everybody
with the clear vision and/or the right
producers you fill me and look Simon
Cowell threw his support for all the
girls too when I caught up with him at
the AGT red carpet last night Nicki came
to normalise defense in particular but I
want to ask you I mean what kind of
success you see the girls having is it
gonna be similar to 1d where everyone
kind of had a piece of the pie you know
I was gonna is there enough room for all
of them I hope so I mean look that's
what's happened with the One Direction
guys I mean Camilla was the first to say
she wanted to go solo and obviously
we've backed her on that and last night
was a huge night for her but all those
girls I mean they're all talented and so
I'm happy for all of them that's look
that's the reason why we do these shows
right yeah you know what I think my knee
strikes five times for you so you have
it folks Simon knows a thing or two of
our making stars okay it's just too bad
that last night's America's Got Talent
was plagued with some technical glitches
though so many to say
we have these really cool doors but
they're not working right now that are
broken live show means sometimes things
happen I think we got cursed tonight by
sacred Rihanna she's really creeped out
Mel B don't you think and I'm always
like no it's fake its fake its fake Mel
right she creeps I believe I can I can
actually see the water flux going into
her eyes it's like she no she doesn't
like this at all I don't like Brianna go
we're talking about her I'm talking
about
what do we see on TV it went completely
black in the house and everyone started
screaming she is really scary like I try
to talk to her she just doesn't break oh
god here she is sacred Rihanna hi girl
kukuku
you're really scary you know that right
okay yeah uh-huh she knows it what did
you think of Heidi's comments you she
was only when I gave you a pretty harsh
critique I disagreed to I was like no no
Heidi you're wrong you're wrong my girl
Rihanna she's gonna take it all the way
aren't you Rihanna okay that's right
well good luck to you you scared the
crap out of me tonight okay
oh no what's a name yeah she didn't
think that was funny
we'll see if the sacred Rihanna makes it
through to the next round tonight on a
GT until then we've got more from last
night's wild live show including trapeze
artist duo transcends second attempt at
their dangerous blindfold trick enjoy
that and I'll see you guys tomorrow